hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir
befinden uns gerade in meiner wohnung
ich glaube wir haben uns hier schon
ziemlich lange nicht mehr gesehen die
letzte videos waren ja alle aus dem büro
wir haben 09
ich glaube so lange habe ich schon
ewigkeiten video mehr aufgenommen in
meinen früheren youtube zeiten war das
ganz normal aber irgendwie hat sich das
verändert naja müssen wir wieder
aufleben lassen das machen wir jetzt
wieder öfter
wir sitzen heute hier weil ich das habe
ich mir immer schon den kopf gesetzt
also halt so in den letzten monaten dass
wenn ich mit meinen restposten projekten
die 10.000 euro knackte also 10.000 euro
ausgegeben dass ich damals ein kleines
fazit hier wie viel ich eigentlich damit
verdient habe weil ihr wisst ja vieles
davon verkaufe ich weiter und ich dachte
mal das interessiert bestimmt auch den
ein oder anderen von euch da draußen ob
sich das ganze lohnt so eine letzten
jahres habe ich damit angefangen
allerdings waren diese videos also ich
habe die sache nicht weiter verkauft ich
habe das dann immer verschenkt oder
verlost aber irgendwann habe ich dann
größer gedacht und dachte mir wenn du so
viel geld der rein steckt irgendwo muss
das geld ja auch zurückkommen weil ich
kann da nicht jede woche 2000 euro in
irgendwelche restposten pakete stecken
und das geld dann nie wieder sehen so
reich bin ich dann nun leider doch auch
noch nicht dann bin ich halt auf die
idee mit meinem eigenen shop gekommen
lucky dog ii.de und dort habe ich das
größtenteils dann immer weiter verkauft
ich habe mir hier eine tabelle
angefertigt mit allen videos dazu das
sind insgesamt glaube ich zwölf stück
die gehen wir jetzt mal gemeinsam durch
ihr seht dann auch immer noch kleiner
ausschnitt davon eingeblendet und ich
verrate euch dann immer was ich dafür
bezahlt habe für dieses video dafür die
sache nicht in dem video ausgepackt und
was sich dann letztendlich damit
verdient habt nach ein zwei wochen als
die alle sachen halt verkauft hat aus
diesem paket ganz kurz allerdings noch
ein anderes thema und zwar war ich vor
zirka zwei wochen in hamburg mit sg
zusammen wir haben dort ein geiles video
gedreht und zwar anlässlich der amazon
prime videoserie panic die ist nämlich
heute raus gekommen und ich verrate euch
am ende des videos noch wie ihre sachen
im wert von 1500 euro gewinnen könnt die
wir auf dem kanal von amazon prime video
erspielt haben eventuell aber jetzt hier
schon mal ein ganz kleiner trailer
hey ich bin sebastian von mein name ist
alex wir sind hier heute in einem
riesigen autorin
anlässlich der serie panic bei einem
video wir müssen geile challenges
erledigen und ich werde ich mich ab
ziehen
okay leute ich bin jetzt echt wirklich
mal gespannt wir starten mit dem ersten
video oder diese restposten reihe
startete wenn ich mich zurückerinnere im
dezember und zwar habe ich dort zehn
restposten laptops aus polen bestellt
starten einfach mal hier mit hier haben
wir einen lenovo chrome boden auch ein
chromebook hier haben wir ein kleineres
chromebook glaube hier haben wir ja
steht nicht drauf was ist es ist ja auch
irgendwas von lenovo der kontakt kam
zustande über so ein portal das heißt
restposten 24 kann ich jetzt eigentlich
keinem empfehlen weil da land wirklich
nur schrott man muss halt wirklich sagen
die guten sachen bekommst du nur über
kontakte du brauchst du guten kontakt du
kannst dich irgendwie im internet suchen
das habe ich jetzt halt gelernt und
deswegen werden auch viele coole sachen
in zukunft kommen weil ich mir schon so
ein kleines ja so einen kleinen
kontaktkreis aufbauen konnte diese zehn
laptops habe ich allerdings ziemlich
schnell verkauft damals noch gar nicht
warm einen eigenen shop sondern über
andere sachen wie instagram und so und
ausgegeben habe ich dafür 1118 euro
verdient habe ich 1715 euro also 397
euro gewinnen ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe auch deutlich mehr
gehofft aber da habe ich gemerkt das ist
gar nicht mal so einfach weiter ging es
mit einem der größten flops und zwar
habe ich zehn random ipads ebenfalls
über diese plattform bestellt wenn einem
kunden per e-mail fragt sind da wirklich
auch ipads hierbei in welchen größen
ungefähr darauf schreiben ja fast
ausschließlich soll mit 200 megabyte und
da sind nur 12 denker das macht nicht
wirklich aggressiv und ich sollte halt
eigentlich nur ipads 4 erhalten
allerdings waren das dann zweier und die
hatten eigentlich gar keinen wert mehr
da war noch der alte anschluss bei da
habe ich 812 euro ausgegeben und konnte
dann mit mühe 566 euro erzielen
allerdings war mehr safe nicht raus zu
holen dann kam ich so langsam auf die
idee mit meinem shop und habe dann netto
restposten bestellt ebenfalls noch mal
über diese besagte seit ich wollte es
halt einfach noch mal versuchen dann
muss ich alles einzeln auspacken und
hero räumen
ich sehe schon relativ viel voll ja mit
einigen sachen nach unten kann ich was
anfang mit den anderen erwähnt was darin
ist habe ich überhaupt keine ahnung und
hier
da ist halt nochmal ultra viel schrott
drin ausgegeben habe ich dafür hat 96
euro verdient 599 euro das war echt so
viel schrott der da drin war und es hat
auch ein bisschen gedauert bis ich das
alles losgeworden bin aber irgendwie
ging jetzt mit der zeit alles weg und
klar ich musste die ganzen sachen auch
verschicken das kostet dann auch noch
mal ein bisschen was also das war eher
so eine plus minus null nummer dann habe
ich mir gedacht okay kommen ich habe vor
weihnachten schon hin und wieder mal bei
saturn so pakete gekauft mit doppelten
warenwert versucht das einfach nochmals
gab dann wieder welche dann habe ich
einfach eingekauft 500 euro wir starten
hier noch mal entspannt reisen mit einem
500 euro paketes sind zwei pakete die
sind hier angekommen
die haben einen garantierten mindestwert
von 1000 euro das hat ganz gut geklappt
da waren halbwegs gute sachen drin und
ich habe 822 euro damit verdient also
322 euro gewinnen warum auch immer
dachte ich dann okay du versuchst auch
mal mit textilien und ich hab so von
adidas und reebok nike ich glaub wohl
nike war glaube ich gar nicht dabei okay
wir haben hier wirklich sportartikel das
wusste ich gar nicht ich dachte
eigentlich dass es auch streetwear
das war so ein ganz dubiose
kontaktaufnahme ich kauf' streetwear und
das waren aber alles so so sportsachen
und da habe ich 200 euro für bezahlt
oder ich glaube sogar 220 euro irgendwie
so und habe aber nur 140 euro damit
verdient weil ich auch gar keinen bock
hatte das alles einzeln
weiterzuverkaufen
dann habe ich da drei pakete
rausgeballert und das war dann halt
einfach wieder weg also dann habe ich
auch die finger wieder von textilien
gelassen weil da kenne ich mich noch
nicht so weit aber dann wurde es
eigentlich interessant und zwar dachte
ich okay ich mache jetzt das ganz große
geld ich habe das war so eine lage
auflösung in hamburg glaube ich so ein
shopping corona sind die pleite gegangen
die hatten auch ganz viel von apple
und da konnte man dann so pakete weise
produkte von dort kaufen und ich habe
ein paket gekauft für 550 euro
mit acht bis zehn random apple-produkten
da hat dann drei oder vier iphones drin
airports und so weiter hier haben wir
ein iphone 5 es das zweite und ich muss
sagen das von euch aus gesehen rechte
ist deutlich besser erhalten
als dieses jahr 550 euro habe ich
bezahlt das problem war ein iphone davon
ging nicht mehr richtig das konnte ich
nicht für so viel geld verkaufen und ich
habe auch noch einen verlust an euch und
da habe ich dann auch nur 460 euro dran
verdient ja dann habe ich noch für 1000
euro bei media markt bestellt
70.000 euro aus aber ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß media markt sagt auch immer man
bekommt den doppelten warenwert das hat
nicht ganz hingehauen also ich hab das
dann hochkriegen ich glaube da leicht an
so bei 1700 euro neuwertig und ich
konnte das dann schlussendlich für 1340
euro alles verkaufen also auch hier 340
euro gewinnen da muss echt ganz nice und
zu habe ich für 3000 euro bei saturn
bestellt ich weiß leute ich habe euch
auch noch versprochen für 10.000 euro
dort einzukaufen wenn es diese box
wieder gibt werde ich das auch tun
dann wird es ganz wild da freue ich mich
schon drauf allerdings ist sie gerade
irgendwie nicht zu kaufen diese 3000
euro habe ich bezahlt
ich hoffe hier drin sitzt jetzt wichtig
wert also muss eigentlich weiter
wer ist enttäuscht und wir legen als ich
noch bei unterm strich habe ich vier
1690 euro umsatz damit gemacht das ging
echt ganz gut wir hatten kameras den
objektiven den laptop das ging echt
schnell weg und eine kamera davon habe
ich auch noch verlost und hätte ich
sogar über 5000 euro damit verdient also
kann man sagen eigentlich so 2000 euro
gewinnen hier sind dann ist halt nur
1690 aber immerhin kann man nicht
meckern oder also an sich waren diese
media markt/saturn pakete nie verkehrt
und ich hab damit immer ganz gut
verdient also du musst halt nur leute
finden die das kaufen dafür braucht ihr
aber eigentlich auch keinen eigenen shop
macht euch einfach in ebay konto ich
habe zum beispiel auch zwei produkte
über ebay verkauft über mir im shop
nicht weg ging das ging dann auch recht
schnell
dann wird es verrückt und zwar habe ich
eine amazon- retouren palette gekauft
ich wusste nicht was wird das wird das
gut ich dachte es wird schrott und
nichts davon funktioniert ich habe dich
für 300 euro gekauft also das war alles
elektronikprodukte von raketen
wir haben jetzt zweimal marina dass so
ein aquarium und habe daran etwas über
1100 euro verdient also einfach mal kurz
verdreifacht ich habe keine ahnung warum
ich hatte halt extrem ist glück und das
gehört halt auch mal dazu ich hatte da
vier drucker drin und einen davon habe
ich für 200 euro verkauft im internet
gab es dann sogar für 600 also komplett
neue von samsung in so ein ding das war
auf jeden fall sehr nice dann habe ich
nochmal für 1100 euro restposten
bestellt von unserem händler aus
frankfurt
das kriegen wir das ist viel zu viel
jetzt ist mir das hier aufgebrochen auf
dem boden und alles ist rausgefallen
scheiße was soll s das waren allerdings
alles er so china produkte amazon fb
sachen falls euch das was sagt und die
habe ich auch zum großen teil aller
losbekommen für etwas mehr 1790 euro
steht hier genau also auch da mal eben
690 euro dran verdient dann hatten wir
noch zwei pakete von media markt und
saturn für ihn zusammen 500 euro 250
euro pro paket ist meine idee und zwar
dachte ich mir ich vergleiche einfach
mal 1 250 euro paket von saturn mit
einem 250 euro paket von media markt da
habe ich 760 euro mit verdient also auch
da 260 euro gewinn und zu guter letzt
die letzte amazon retouren palette vom
letzten video da habe ich 320 euro
ausgegeben und 430 euro mit verdient
also hier waren es dann leider nur 110
euro gewinnen und bei der davor 800 euro
also es ist so krass wie man die man
also du musst halt einfach auch glück
haben und die richtigen kontakte dann
kann man auf jeden fall in dieser
restposten branche
wenn man da mal rein steckt das ist auch
recht aufwendig aber dann kannst du da
echt geld verdienen das muss ich sagen
das ist so das habe ich für mich ist auf
jeden fall so gelernt und ich bin
gespannt was noch kommt und wie sich das
ganze noch so weiterentwickelt jetzt
kommen wir zum gesamtgewinn insgesamt
habe ich zehn 1096 euro ausgeben für
meine ganzen sachen und verdient habe
ich 14 1412 euro also gut 440 euro
gewinnen kann man nicht meckern oder das
ist jetzt natürlich nicht die welt aber
einfach mal so 4000 euro nebenher warum
eigentlich nicht und was ja das
wichtigste ist es ist auch an sich immer
nur ein hobby gewesen ich habe das
irgendwie gefühlt und gefeiert so etwas
zu machen aber so ein bisschen
auszupacken und ja deswegen alles cool
ihr könnt auf jeden fall super gerne mal
kommentieren ob ihr gedacht hätte dass
ich damit noch deutlich mehr geld
verdient hätte oder vielleicht auch ein
bisschen weniger ansonsten habe ich am
anfang des videos ja schon von dem
gewinnspiel auf dem amazon prime
videokanal erzählt ihr könnt ihr einfach
irgendwo klicken dann kommt ihr zum
video zusammen mit escape check das auf
jeden fall ab ist super lustig geworden
und ja das war von mir wir sehen uns
sonntag wieder gibt's neues geiles video
abonniert super g den kanal und dank für
zuschauer die haut rein